you
[Music]
imagine you're on a game show and you
can choose between two prizes a diamond
or a bottle of water it's an easy choice
the diamonds are clearly more valuable
now imagine being given the same choice
again only this time you're not on a
game show
but dehydrated in the desert after
wandering for days do you choose
differently why aren't diamonds still
more valuable this is the paradox of
value famously described by pioneering
economist Adam Smith and what it tells
us is that defining value is not as
simple as it seems
on the game show you were thinking about
each items exchange value what you could
obtain for them at a later time but in
an emergency like the desert scenario
what matters far more is their use value
how helpful they are in your current
situation and because we only get to
choose one of the options we also have
to consider its opportunity cost or what
we lose by giving up the other choice
after all it doesn't matter how much you
could get from selling the diamond if
you never make it out of the desert
most modern economists deal with the
paradox of value by attempting to unify
these considerations under the concept
of utility how well something satisfies
a person's once or needs utility can
apply to anything from the basic need
for food to the pleasure of hearing a
favorite song and will naturally vary
for different people and circumstances a
market economy provides us with an easy
way to track utility put simply the
utility something has to you is
reflected by how much you'd be willing
to pay for it now imagine yourself back
in the desert only this time you get
offered a new diamond or a fresh bottle
of water every five minutes if you're
like most people you'll first choose
enough water to last the trip and then
as many diamonds as you can carry this
is because of something called marginal
utility and it means that when you
choose between diamonds and water you
compare utility obtained from every
additional bottle of water to every
additional diamond and you do this each
time an offer is made the first bottle
of water is worth more to you than any
amount of diamonds but eventually you
have all the water you need
after a while every additional bottle
becomes a burden that's when you begin
to choose diamonds over water and it's
not just necessities like water when it
comes to most things the more that you
acquire the less useful or enjoyable
every additional bit becomes this is the
law of diminishing marginal utility
you might gladly buy two or three
helpings of your favorite food
but the fourth would make you nauseated
and the hundreds would spoil before you
could even get to it or you could pay to
see the same movie over and over until
you got bored of it or spent all of your
money either way you'd eventually reach
a point where the marginal utility for
buying another movie ticket became zero
utility applies not just to buying
things but to all our decisions and the
intuitive way to maximize it and avoid
diminishing returns is to vary the way
we spend our time and resources after
our basic needs are met we theoretically
decide to invest in choices only to the
point they're useful or enjoyable of
course how effectively any of us manage
to maximize utility in real life is
another matter but it helps to remember
that the ultimate source of value comes
from us the needs we share the things we
enjoy and the choices we make
Oh
[Music]